Here we will learn
to distinguish
between vectors and scalars.
Vectors are objects that
have both a magnitude,
a single number,
and a direction.
Whereas scalars have
only a magnitude.
Let's see some examples of each.
The length of
something is a scalar
because it's just the magnitude.
A force exerted by
someone pulling something
is a vector because we
care about the strength
of the force, the
magnitude, and the direction
in which the force is acting.
Temperature-- it's a scalar.
If we display temperature
on a weather map
where the value
of the temperature
is different at each point in
space, this is a scalar field.
In comparison, this
weather map of wind
where the value of the wind
velocity at each point in space
is represented by a
vector is a vector field.